To me, the largest area of work for the future:...
...energy and water are the real solutions to health, livelihood,...
...all of the stuff that goes above it.
Most people don't realize, but half the world either has no electricity...
...or electricity two, three hours a day.
Everything requires energy.
Energy is the great equalizer.
So you try to look for that, which is the one thing that will lead to benefits...
...that are across hundreds of things.
Human mechanical energy is so amazing.
Why can't we use that to create energy?
So, we've invented a hybrid bicycle that you pedal for an hour,...
...and you have electricity for 24 hours.
We call it Free Electric.
The Free Electric, I think, is the coolest of all our inventions...
...and yet it's going to affect,...
...maybe have the largest effect of anything in the last hundred years.